we've finally seen more of god of war
ragnarok at sony's september playstation
showcase developer sony santa monica has
revealed a bunch of info about the game
so here's everything we know so far for
more videos on god of war make sure to
like this video and subscribe and beware
spoilers ahead for the end of god of war
2018
yes as the name suggests ragnarok the
fabled end of the world in norse
mythology is coming and kratos and
atreus are desperately trying to stop it
but it's not going to be an easy task
kratos and atreus got pretty entangled
in the norse gods affairs in god of war
and made many enemies along the way that
they'll now have to deal with as well as
trying to stop the end of the world they
killed baldur son of freya and odin and
a once friendly freya is out for revenge
according to santa monica studio we
wanted to remind players that freya
isn't just a terrifyingly powerful user
of vania magic but also that she's a
formidable warrior in her own right
enraged by kratos evasion of justice by
her hand freya will turn every weapon at
her disposal towards her son's killer
are you a calm and reasonable person
we also caught a glimpse of thor in the
post-credits of god of war looking for
you guessed it revenge for the death of
his sons modi and magni and his
half-brother balder santa monica said
thor's legendary bloodlust and wrath
will be aimed at kratos and atreus
referred to disparagingly by mimir as
the biggest butchering bastard in the
nine realms thor earned his title as one
of the most powerful asia gods by wiping
out nearly all the giants at odin's
command now if this doesn't sound like
the thor you know i seriously recommend
picking up neil gaiman's norse mythology
for a primer on
this thaw
let's just say he's uh something else
entirely is he though and speaking of
giants like i said they're not exactly
the all father odin's favorites and he
has long been at war with them he had
thor try and wipe them out and he
imprisoned his other son tyr for helping
them now we believe tyr to be dead in
the first game but it looks like we're
going to be meeting him in ragnarok the
giants had the gift of foresight and at
the end of god of war kratos uncovered a
prophecy where it was revealed that his
wife was actually a giant named lauthy
not only is atreus part giant he was
also given the name loki at birth and is
somehow involved in ragnarok so much for
not getting involved in the aco's
affairs you're nuts i'll rip your head
off with regard to atreus santa monica
studio revealed that like most young
people he wants to understand who he is
more than anything
in this case he wants to understand who
he could be the mystery of loki's role
in the upcoming conflict is something
that atreus cannot let go of he wants to
keep his family safe but atreus also
doesn't want to stand by and do nothing
while conflict consumes the nine realms
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there
finding out who i am who loki is but the
usually bloodthirsty kratos seems to
wish to take a different path a line
from the game's description insinuates
that he is intent on helping to spare
atreus from the bloody lessons he
learned from his conflict with gods he
wants to keep his son safe above all and
their confrontation with balder has
vindicated the belief that only tragedy
will come from further entanglements
with the aesir together kratos and
atreus will have to make a choice about
which path they will take whatever they
choose will define the fate of all those
living in the nine realms as ragnarok
approaches
which leads us quite nicely into combat
2018's god of war was praised for its
crunchy combat mechanics and systems and
sony santa monica has pledged to carry
forward that spirit and tradition
as a team we've worked hard to take our
learnings from god of war 2018 and
improve upon combat to feel fresh yet
familiar with god of war ragnarok one of
our main goals was to push player choice
in combat whether it's through hard
hitting combos a mastery of elements or
clever defensive tactics you will find
plenty of opportunities to fight
alongside our duo in a way that feels
uniquely expressive which is great
because not only do you have gods on
your tail but the other enemies in
ragnarok will be harsher and more varied
with kratos and atreya set to take on a
host of new creatures from across norse
mythology some of the new enemies
revealed so far include the stalker and
the drachi
whereas 2018's god of war allowed
players to visit six of the nine realms
ragnarok goes further and takes you to
all nine this includes vanaheim
svartalfheim and asgard which were not
in the first game new areas from
previous locations have been added to
ragnarok as well according to santa
monica studios exploring the realms will
take you everywhere from verdant
otherworldly jungles to intricate
subterranean mining networks this next
installment in the series will bring you
a more diverse beautiful and mysterious
variety of locations than in any other
god of war game
christopher judge and sunny soljic
returned to voice kratos and atreus
while ryan hurst who played opie and
sons of anarchy has joined the cast as
thor
leia de leon hayes plays anger border
while ben prendergast portrays tear
richard schiff will be playing odin
returning from the 2018 game is bear
mccreary to once again compose the music
the new trailer from the playstation
showcase includes a tease of the new
tunes and according to mccreary's
twitter it includes a significant new
character theme which sounds both very
ominous and very exciting
corey barlog directed 2018's god of war
as well as 2007's god of war 2 but he's
not returning to direct the sequel
stepping in is eric williams a veteran
of the series to direct ragnarok
speaking to vgc williams said it's
always been a tradition here at santa
monica to change the directors across
the games we've had really good success
with that corey is the only repeat
director and rightfully so he's damn
good at what he does corey barlock added
the important thing for us is to be able
to get a fresh perspective each time but
also a fresh pair of legs in the sense
that you're really exhausted at the end
of finishing one of these things so
you've got to con somebody else into
doing it
now you are ready
[Music]
god of war ragnarok is planned for ps5
but it's also coming to ps4 the news of
a previous gen version was quietly
shared via a q a with hermann holst the
head of playstation studios at the
september playstation showcase sony
confirmed that ragnarok will be released
across ps5 and ps4 although there is no
word yet on any big differences between
the editions that might exist
and what about pc well this is all
speculative right now given sony's
recent track record of slowly bringing
some of its biggest playstation games to
pc it does make sense to question the
possibility for a pc version of god of
war ragnarok sony also recently acquired
the pc port specialist nix's software
fueling rumors that it might bring more
of its first-party games to pc to help
expand their audience while a pc edition
of ragnarok hasn't been confirmed yet
hulst mentioned in an interview on the
playstation blog that the company
continues to further invest in the pc
space but if it's anything like previous
sony releases on pc it's likely not to
come to the platform for some time if it
ever does
we'll let you know when we do
if you're interested in a
behind-the-scenes look at how the 2018
god of war was made check out our
episode of audio logs where game
director corey barlog breaks down one of
the most pivotal scenes how it was
created and the crucial gameplay
mechanic that was almost cut from the
game
and we really had to figure out how to
take the old moves and make them work
much better in this camera angle for
more god of war make sure to like this
video and subscribe and we'll catch you
next time
you'll get your answer soon enough
well some of them
[Music]
you